[Música]
un emprendedor es aquella persona capaz
de identificar una oportunidad de
negocio en base a esta organiza una
serie de herramientas para poner en
marcha un proyecto empresarial que tiene
como objetivo alcanzar a la libertad
financiera y generar utilidades minar
mucho dinero orden corte
qué les parece si sólo por esta vez
dejamos de lado todos estos conceptos
usuales y comunes y nos enfocamos en la
verdadera esencia de un emprendedor su
espíritu como individuo y ser humano
porque si emprendimiento solamente
fueran empresas y negocios entonces
donde quedarían los hombres externos
tales como picasso einstein marie curie
o borges hoy en día no conocemos una
empresa llamada dalí s a dsb y te cobran
por descargar la tesis de la relatividad
general y cervantes escribió sus libros
en la cárcel él no imaginaba que iban a
tener tanto valor monetario pensemos en
una mujer no es acaso un ser humano
inherentemente digno al igual que un
varón esto se respeta hoy en día gracias
a personas como clara campoamor que fue
la pionera en lograr que se valide el
sufragio femenino en europa no es acaso
en una emprendedora tal vez yo me
equivoqué y la libertad pese menos que
un lingote de oro es por eso que este
día me gustaría tomarme el atrevimiento
contigo de crear una
definición de emprendedor que incluye a
todas estas personas un emprendedor es
aquel que sueña se enamora de ese sueño
idea cómo traerlo a la realidad lo
ejecuta y trasciende gracias a ese sueño
y este sueño es la semilla la parte más
delicada del emprendimiento porque
apenas se está gestando debe ser cuidado
tú no puedes dejar que tu sueño sea roto
por nadie ni puede romper el sueño de
alguien más porque esto podría cambiar
el curso completo de la humanidad y no
exagero un joven austriaco que perdió a
su padre a los 12 años a su madre a los
15 pero fue arrojado a la pobreza y la
miseria y él decía con una maleta de
roca en la mano derecha y una voluntad
inquebrantable en la izquierda y uno
claudicaría seguiría mi sueño de ser
igual que mi padre de ser a alguien yo
quería ser arquitecto decía él soñaba
con diseñar y trabajaba como pintor
hasta que dejó que rompan sus sueños y
hoy en día conocemos a esta persona como
adolf hitler
te imaginas cuánto hubiera cambiado la
historia por una palabra de aliento por
un abrazo por un tú puedes pequeño árbol
no te rindas
tú puedes no dejes que rompa en tu sueño
aunque el entorno sea hostil tú puedes
es por eso que para que nuestros sueños
no sean frágiles es necesario que tengan
cimientos sólidos y lo primero que se
debe hacer es mirar en el interior hacer
una introspección de lo más abstracto
del ser humano que su espíritu porque
cuando te mires dentro de ti será tu
espíritu el que te responda qué vas a
emprender dando lugar a un estilo tuyo
propio único y este estilo te responderá
el cómo vas a emprender el filósofo
alemán arthur schopenhauer menciona que
cuando el espíritu humano se manifiesta
da como lugar algo original y único pero
cuando se trata de copiar el estilo
ajeno simplemente se consigue algo
mediocre y descolorido piénsalo por eso
es que hay tantos artistas pasajeros
tantas empresas que fracasan tantos
emprendedores que no pueden lograr el
éxito porque solamente tratan de
replicar pero tú y yo debemos ser
creadores y no solamente replicadores de
lo contrario seremos un cascarón
colorido pero sin substancia como dice
residente mucha selva y poco tigre mucha
pólvora y poco calibre
sólo entonces será que tú podrás mirar
hacia afuera porque tu entorno te dará
la respuesta de cuál es tu objetivo y
cuál es tu objeto el objeto te
responderá el por qué emprendes y el
objetivo el para que emprendes traigamos
a dalí para entender estos conceptos en
el espíritu de dalí le mandaba a que el
expresa y manifiesta sus sueños y su
amor por su esposa gala su estilo era la
manera única que tenía de pintar hasta
sus bigotes eran parte de su estilo su
objeto en el arte en sí mismo y su
objetivo pero el oro él buscaba riquezas
y eso no está mal pero es decir lo
primero que hago es a mi esposa gala
luego el oro aún así él no dejaba que el
oro aunque su arte y dejaba que su
estilo pese más que su espíritu
este hombre decidió ser eterno y tú te
preguntarás y cómo puedo ser eterno yo
también cómo puedo ser como ellos la
diferencia entre ellos y tú es que ellos
tenían talento y tú no cierto no la
única diferencia entre los eternos y
nosotros es la disciplina que ellos
tuvieron para ejecutar
sueños y traerlos a la realidad esa es
la única diferencia porque ellos
realmente persiguieron cosas eternas
ellos decidieron vivir para siempre pero
tú cuánto tiempo quieres vivir porque
está en tus manos decidirlo el ser
humano muere dos veces cuando su corazón
late por última vez y cuando su nombre
es pronunciado por última vez tú puedes
ser eterno también y esto estará
condicionado por la manera en lo que en
la que tú vivas como ser humano
explotando tus propias características
cuando tú te conviertas en tu mejor arma
y te conviertas en tu mejor obra de arte
porque cuando tú miras un animal tú
miras un león por ejemplo que está
cazando el cachorro de una cebra este
animal no piensa oh pobre cebra tal vez
tiene sueño si algún día quiere
emprender a lo mejor me comería una
cebra más vieja no simplemente se la
come pero cuál es su diferencia tú como
ser humano puede sentir misericordia un
animal no puede sentir compasión puedes
mirar a tu alrededor y preguntarte cómo
puedo crear una sociedad en la que al
menos todos tengan un pan en la mesa
esto más que ser un emprendedor es ser
humano porque solo así cuando tú llegues
a la cima
tendrás quien celebre contigo porque de
otro modo lo único que te espera es la
muerte y esa es otra característica que
tú y yo compartimos como seres humanos
tú y yo sabemos que vamos a morir y eso
es hermoso un animal vive en el presente
solamente muere pero tú y yo es como que
tuviéramos una última cena tú tuvieras
la última oportunidad de disfrutar tu
platillo favorito qué harías acaso no lo
probaría bocado a bocado sin dejar que
nadie te interrumpa ese momento tan
especial no es la vida de esta manera no
sabemos que tenemos una sola no vale la
pena disfrutarla en base a nuestro
espíritu propio a la vez que somos
misericordiosos y compass y tenemos
compasión por los demás
el hombre que persigue bienes efímeros
será olvidado pero aquel que persigue
bienes eternos vivirá para siempre la
riqueza y la fama son endebles y
pasajeras piensa en jackman el hombre
más rico de china en su momento y el
fundador de alibaba
el en una entrevista dijo que si pudiera
volver el tiempo no fundaría alibaba y
no se dedicaría a ello porque su esposa
le reclamaba ya que tú no me perteneces
a mí ni le perteneces a tus hijos le
perteneces a alibaba
él hubiera preferido guardar su
privacidad pero ahora tiene el peso de
la fama y el dinero sobre sus hombros y
tiene que elegir el oro sobre su familia
porque el éxito de un emprendedor no
está condicionado por toda la riqueza
material que obtenga alguien que
emprende para poder llenar más sus
bolsillos no es más que alguien que
emprende para llevar un poco de comida
para su familia
o alguien que se le ocurrió limpiar los
zapatos y cobrar por ello no es acaso
hace un modelo de negocio éstos
lustrabotas por ejemplo en bolivia ellos
se cubren el rostro porque les da
vergüenza que les vean haciendo este
trabajo pero prefieren hacer esto que
robar y delinquir
no valen estos hombres no son
emprendedores
el valor de un emprendedor pesa en
proporción al amor que sienta por lo que
hace sin importar si nadie lo conoce o
lo reconoce y quiero que seas tú el que
juzgue si esto es cierto o no porque
ahora voy a contarte el sueño de una
emprendedora
cuando yo daba clases de guitarra a
niños y jóvenes llegó una mujer que
tenía cerca de 60 y 65 años
le costaba mucho aprender porque era
mayor ella practicaba pero temblaba en
sus manos le costaba coordinar ya se
olvidaba a una silla no se rendía yo me
preguntaba por qué se esforzaba tanto y
ella un día me dijo profesor yo nunca me
casé ni
tuve hijos solamente tenía mi madre y
ella murió hace un mes
ahora lo único que me queda es mi sueño
de poder tocar en la guitarra la canción
que me hace recuerdo a ella y yo la veía
esforzarte tanto pero a veces ella se
desesperaba y me decía profesor ya no
puedo y le decía no se rinda señora inés
yo no voy a dejar que se rinda usted
puede pero me decía pero profesor es que
me duele me duele en mis manos no se
rinda y sabes que seis meses después
ella lo logró yo logro tocar la canción
que tanto amaba porque su espíritu pesó
más y sabes qué es lo irónico cuando yo
estaba en su lugar aprendiendo a tocar
la guitarra mi profesor me dijo sabes no
tienes talento
deberías dejarlo y dedicarte algo más
productivo pero no me importó mi
espíritu' pesó más y llevo diez años
tocando la guitarra y en esta mujer pesó
más su espíritu y vivirá a través de mi
ella vivirá a través de mí porque
conozco su historia ahora tú conoces su
historia y vivirá a través de ti y tú
vivirás a través de todas aquellas
personas
con tu naturaleza original como ser
humano que es ser noble
porque la única forma de lidiar con un
mundo sin libertad es convertirnos en
tan absolutamente libres que nuestra
mera existencia se convierta en un acto
de rebelión
jamás olvides
que tu más grande emprendimiento
es tu propia vida
[Música]